a warning it contains images of severely
injured children from the start
it's a week since the bombing of the
train station in krematorsk and doctors
want to show us the cost
jana is 10.
she was at the station with her mother
last friday fleeing the fighting further
east
she lost one of her legs the other foot
and her mother
next door katarina she's 12.
doctors saved her badly injured legs and
yet she too lost her mother
goodness knows their trauma and
understandably doctors have asked that
we didn't show their faces or interview
them
but then what more needs to be heard
andre was at the station too
the three young ukrainians were with
thousands as they tried to board trains
away from danger when it was targeted by
the missile he's now without his arm
is a quiet and a calmness here but it's
not safe the windows are prepared for
whatever might come next
the city of denipro is split by the
river a buffer for ukraine against any
advance by the russians from the east
for now the whole city is firmly in
ukrainian control but this week russian
missiles hit the city's new airport
on the east side of the river is the
dinipro branch of the ukrainian
association for the blind
a place that's now a refuge for anyone
who needs it
among those here three generations of
one family they're from the countries
far east
two meters away from our shelter the
bombs landed she tells me for 24 days we
were living below ground when the
electricity was cut we decided we had to
leave
in the quiet of the corridor we found
larissa bovina she describes this place
as heaven and from the hell she's
escaped it certainly is
so complex
with there were a whole range of
feelings she tells me in my hands my
legs my ears the vibration from the
bombs
this is the experience of war for the
blind
thank you very much for for sparing the
time to talk to us the city's mayor is
boris filitov he doesn't stay in one
place for long the russians have said
they will target command centers this
isn't a military command center but he
won't take his chances
we need
three
things
weapon weapon and weapon
and the american president has said 800
million dollars worth of weapons will be
coming
yes we are
very happy and
tell us
thank you for our uh western friends
but
western help
is late late early
the challenges for dinipro are huge
caring for the wounded and the displaced
but also preparing as much as they can
for the days ahead
mark stone sky news in ukraine